تسير حالات الإصابة بالفيروس التاجي في ألاباما
في الاتجاه الخاطئ
الذي تتجه إليه ، لكن الولاية
مفتوحة الآن على مصراعيها للتباعد الاجتماعي للأعمال
هو قاعدة الولاية ، لكن هذا
الجهد غالبًا ما كان تمرينًا على
العبث في المطاعم والحانات في
مدن الشاطئ في ألاباما هذا النصب التذكاري  في
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ، حيث يعود الناس للاحتفال في
هذا البار الحديدي الصدئ في جلف شورز
ألاباما ، يتساءل الكثيرون لماذا استغرق الأمر
وقتًا طويلاً لفتحه
، أنا هنا فقط للاستمتاع
والجميع يكون رائعًا عبر
الشارع ، الشاطئ مزدحم.
من المفترض أن تكون على بعد ستة أقدام من بعضها
البعض ، تعمل الشرطة لفرض أن
المجموعات مؤمنة أيضًا بأن تتكون فقط
من الأشخاص الذين يعيشون في نفس المنزل ،
ولا توجد جهود نشطة لفرض
أن كار تبلغ مؤخرًا من العمر 21 عامًا تخرجت للتو
من الكلية ، لكنني  أعني أنني
لا أريد ذلك ولكن أعني أنه إذا كان هذا
ما يخبئه الله لحياتي ، فإن
عائلتي لديها نفس العقلية مثلي وقد اتفقنا
نوعًا ما على أنه إذا
حصلنا عليها فسنتعامل معها على أنها  عائلة
وتجاوز الأمر لأن هذا ما
تفعله الأسرة عندما يتعلق الأمر بفيروس كورونا ،
سيخبرك الخبراء الطبيون أنهم
قلقون للغاية بشأن
المستقبل القريب هنا في ألاباما على هذا الشاطئ على
الرغم من أن عينيك وأذنيك ستخبرك
بشيء مختلف كثيرًا - عن  أي
مخاوف بشأن التواجد على الشاطئ مع
الكثير من الأشخاص في وظيفتك ،
فكيف لا تشعر بالقلق على الإطلاق من
أن يمرض شخص ما ويمشي
ويمرضك لأن هناك ما يكفي من
الرياح والهواء الذي سيتضح الآن
من هنا  الرياح في الهواء لا
تمسحها ، لا يوجد دليل على
أي شيء مثل أن هناك رياح وهواء
في كل مكان في هذا العالم ، ثم
هناك مشكلة الأقنعة التي رأيناها في
المجموع الكلي 0 يتم ارتداؤها على الشاطئ ،
هل سبق لك ذلك  ارتداء قناع ، لا زوجتي وأولادي ،
لا
أشعر بالراحة ، أنا فقط أشعر بالراحة وسأكون على ما يرام ،
لكن القناع لا يجعلك بخير ، بل
هو الحفاظ على زوجتك وأطفالك بخير
[موسيقى]
معدل البقاء على قيد الحياة مرتفع للغاية على
ما أعتقد  لست قلقًا بشأن
مرضهم ، حسنًا ، سأعيش ، سنمرض جميعًا
بسبب شيء ما في النهاية يكون
الرئيس ترامب جزءًا من هذه
المحادثة ، أعني أنه إذا لم يكن يرتدي
قناعًا ، فلن أرتدي قناعًا إذا
لم يكن قلقًا.  أنا لست قلقًا من
الرئيس ، نعم سيدي
يتحدث عن الأقنعة التي فوضها ألاباما
للعاملين في حانة
المطعم ، لكن بعض المطاعم
سيعيدون كتابة مقاطع فيديو غير معلنة ويغلقون الهاتف الخليوي ،
لم يكن الموظفون يرتدون
أقنعة أخبرنا المدير هنا بعد
زيارتنا أنه لديه الآن  أعطى أقنعة
لموظفيه مع تعليمات بارتدائها
في بار المطعم الآخر حيث
لم نر أي موظفين يرتدون أقنعة
أخبرنا المدير أنهم سيستمرون في عدم
ارتدائها لأنها تريدها على هذا
النحو على الرغم من انتهاكها مع
حركة مرور أوامر الدولة كثيفة للغاية في ولاية ألاباما  تم
بيع جميع المدن الشاطئية في جميع الفنادق المجاورة مع بدء
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع في ولاية ألاباما التي عادت إلى
العمل.